Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
Nous allons vous parler
de la situation
du logement en France.
La bombe socio-économique
et environnementale du logement.
Incontestablement, il y a
une crise du logement en France
et aussi affirmativement,
il n'y a pas de véritable
politique du logement.
Ce constat posé,
une kyrielle de problèmes sociaux,
économiques,
fonciers, administratifs,
environnementaux et politiques
viennent scander ce qui constitue
une bombe à fragmentation
humaine et sociale
qui touche
l'ensemble de la population,
excepté la frange la plus aisée
qui dispose de revenus importants.
Cette crise vient pénaliser
considérablement les plus pauvres,
à savoir, d'après le dernier rapport
de la Fondation Abbé Pierre
concernant la France en 2022,
4 millions de personnes mal logées,
voire sous-logées,
et aussi grave, 12 millions
de personnes fragilisées
à des degrés divers
pour se trouver un toit,
subvenir aux dépenses quotidiennes.
En ce qui concerne
le logement étudiant,
il manquerait 250 000 logements.
A l'instar de ce qui s'est produit
avec la révolte des Gilets jaunes
et de l'augmentation
du prix du diesel comme facteur
déclenchant, c'est l'augmentation
ou ça serait
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt
opérée par les banques
sur les crédits immobiliers
qui a mis en exergue
cette crise du logement en France,
au point de provoquer
ce cri du coeur
de Geoffroy Roux de Bézieux,
ancien président du MEDEF :
"La France va
au-devant d'une catastrophe
"dans le domaine du logement."
Nous allons en parler
avec mes invités
que je vous présente.
Emmanuelle Cosse,
vous êtes présidente
de l'Union sociale pour l'Habitat,
vous êtes
ancienne ministre du Logement
et de l'Habitat durable.
Pascal Lagrue,
vous êtes secrétaire confédéral
pour le développement
et le logement à Force Ouvrière.
Michel Cantal-Dupart,
vous êtes architecte, urbaniste,
professeur honoraire au CNAM.
Julien Damon,
vous êtes sociologue, enseignant
à Sciences Po Paris et à HEC.
De la Fondation Abbé Pierre
au MEDEF, vous avez pu le voir,
les mises en garde apostrophent
les pouvoirs publics
sur la crise du logement.
Certes les problèmes
qui touchent les plus pauvres
ne sont pas de même gravité
que ceux qui concernent
le reste de la population,
mais on peut dire
qu'elle est également touchée.
Nous entrerons dans le détail
au fil de la discussion.
Pour commencer,
Emmanuelle Cosse,
quelles sont les mesures d'urgence
que vous préconisez
pour éviter cette catastrophe
dont parle
Geoffroy Roux de Bézieux ?
-La 1re mesure, ce n'en est pas une,
c'est simplement d'admettre
ce que vous venez de dire.
Vous avez fait le constat
que c'est une crise en devenir.
A mon avis, elle est déjà là.
Qu'il y a un risque
d'éclatement social.
C'est partagé par des mouvements
associatifs
comme par le MEDEF et
les partenaires sociaux en général.
Et pourtant, le président
de la République depuis 7 ans,
quand il parle de logement,
ce n'est jamais pour parler de ça.
C'est soit pour dire, le logement,
ça coûte trop cher,
le logement, ça marche pas,
mais jamais pour dire,
il y a une crise sociale,
notre société va mal,
les Français sont mal logés, je dois
trouver des moyens d'améliorer ça,
mobilisons-nous tous ensemble.
C'est ça, la 1re mesure,
un point de vue
politique et après, je pourrais vous
décrire des tas de mesures.
Mais ce qui nous manque le plus,
c'est ce fossé
entre un constat partagé
entre de plus en plus d'acteurs,
ces cris d'alerte que nous poussons
et en face, une non-réponse.
-Mais ils ont essayé avec le Conseil
national de la Refondation.
-Typiquement,
c'est très intéressant.
Le président lance le Conseil
national de la Refondation.
Les partenaires sociaux exigent une
réunion spécifique sur le logement,
elle est convoquée,
on y travaille tous,
il y a 300 acteurs différents
qui y participent,
on produit des tas de trucs
comme on sait faire
et y compris, il y a un bougé
des uns et des autres
pour répondre à l'urgence.
Le résultat, au mois de juin,
une réunion où on nous a dit,
c'était très bien, votre travail,
mais on n'a rien à vous proposer.
Ca a été une douche froide
très forte et depuis, ça,
c'était en juin, objectivement,
il ne s'est rien passé.
Donc je... Vous voyez...
Après, je pourrais
vous décliner des mesures :
aider le logement social,
aider l'accession
à la propriété, libérer
les fonciers, réguler les marchés.
Il y a tous ces sujets-là
qui se posent, mais au-delà,
il y a une question principale
qui est la prise en compte
de cette priorité
et de cette urgence
dans la période actuelle.
-Si vous aviez une mesure
à proposer, une mesure à proposer,
ensuite, on passera
au détail de cette absence
de politique.
Pascal Lagrue, ce serait quoi ?
-Dans les mesures
qu'on aurait à proposer,
c'est qu'on fasse en sorte
que tous les acteurs du logement,
je dis bien tous les acteurs,
que ce soit ceux
qui sont dans le paritarisme,
ceux qui sont, on va dire,
au sein de l'USH au sens large,
fassent en sorte
d'arrêter de jouer au ping-pong
avec les finances
qui financent ce logement,
notamment le social,
pour qu'on puisse
faire en sorte de répondre
à la problématique
emploi-logement. C'est ça
qu'il y a derrière
cette crise du logement. On parlera
un peu plus après
des enjeux sur les emplois.
-On va rentrer dans le détail.
-Mais aujourd'hui,
il y a une chose qui est quand même,
c'est un constat majeur,
avec, en gros, le coût d'une
construction individuelle maison,
qui augmente de plus
de 25 % en 2 ans,
et 40 % de production
de logements en moins,
depuis 2 ans, et bien,
ça veut dire qu'on est vraiment
en état de récession
sur le logement.
Il faut que les fonds
qui sont attribués
au logement
le soient vraiment et qu'on arrête
de jouer au chat et à la souris,
en disant, ça, c'est mon budget, ça,
c'est pas mon budget, etc.
-Et vous, quelle mesure
vous préconiseriez ?
-J'attrape la baguette magique
et je dirais
qu'il faut davantage décentraliser
cette politique du logement.
Ca ne répond pas immédiatement
aux problèmes des gens,
mais ça serait une simplification
nécessaire et possible
de tout cet attirail de politiques
assez compliquées.
La décentraliser, ça veut pas dire
que l'Etat n'aurait
pas son mot à dire,
notamment dans la péréquation
des financements, mais davantage
de responsabilités
qui soient confiées,
à quelle échelle précisément,
les métropoles
ou les intercommunalités.
-Michel Cantal-Dupart,
une mesure pour vous
pour débloquer la situation ?
-Une mesure...
-Après, on rentrera
dans le détail.
-On a connu des problèmes de crise,
c'est pas nouveau.
On s'est donné des ambitions
sur une succession de plans
qui n'étaient pas raisonnables.
Je prends un exemple
sur le Grand Paris.
Il était dit, il faut
construire 70 000 logements
par an. Ca a été dit,
ça a été mis dans la loi.
-On l'a même fait.
-Oui, non, c'est...
-On l'a fait
plusieurs années. Bah oui, mais...
Tu as raison, mais on l'a fait.
-Bon. Il faut,
enfin, la décentralisation,
c'est... bon.
Moi, je pense, j'ai connu
le passage de l'aide à la pierre
à l'aide à la personne.
Je pense qu'il faudrait revisiter
et garder l'aide à la personne,
c'est quand même pas mal,
mais revenir
à une certaine aide à la pierre.
Je me souviens très bien,
les organismes
sociaux étaient montés au créneau
en disant, on court
à la catastrophe, parce que... bon.
On y est. 50 ans après,
quand même. Donc je pense
que c'est une mesure
à... à piocher, à voir.
Et puis,
pour répondre
au problème de crédits,
les gens travaillent
de façon individuelle,
alors, ça peut être le relais
de collectivités territoriales,
mais surtout, il y a une chose
qu'on connaît mal,
mais qui est dans la loi aussi,
c'est l'habitat participatif
et qui permet à un groupement,
un peu comme autrefois
les Castors mais plus moderne,
mais à un groupement
de gens de pouvoir,
parce qu'il y a un groupement,
ils ont peut-être une accession
aux crédits, peut-être,
je ne suis pas banquier...
-C'était à quelle époque,
les Castors ?
-Ils ont surtout
la capacité de discuter
avec les entreprises.
-L'époque des Castors ?
-Après la guerre, la reconstruction.
C'est les gens
qui voulaient faire...
C'était pas les sinistrés,
c'était des gens qui voulaient faire
de l'accession à la propriété
et qui, ensemble,
construisaient leurs maisons.
Ensemble.
Il y avait tous les corps
de métier et ça a eu
un succès formidable.
-Emmanuelle Cosse, vous avez été
ministre. Qu'est-ce que vous prônez
ou vous prôneriez
à l'Etat pour corriger le tir ?
D'un point de vue
institutionnel. Est-ce que
c'est un ministère du Logement
doté de crédits exceptionnels ?
Est-ce que c'est une délégation
auprès du Premier ministre ?
Sur le plan de l'Etat.
-Non, mais simplement,
déjà, un ministre de plein exercice.
Un ministre qui ne soit pas délégué
ou secrétaire d'Etat.
-M. Béchu est...
-Non, M. Vergriete est
ministre du Logement,
délégué auprès
de M. Béchu.
-M. Béchu est
ministre du Logement également.
-Il est ministre du Logement,
de l'Ecologie,
de la Ruralité,
de la Biodiversité et j'en oublie,
des Transports, etc.
-Vous prônez...
-Et je vous dis pourquoi.
J'ai eu cette chance
d'être ministre de plein exercice
et à la table du Conseil
des ministres chaque semaine,
quels que soient les sujets,
toutes les semaines,
puisque j'étais
dans le conseil le plus restreint.
Et donc aussi de pouvoir porter
mes sujets toutes les semaines.
Et avec le Premier ministre
et avec le président
de la République.
Ca vous donne un rang de discussion
avec l'ensemble des ministères
très important.
Vous allez trouver cela futile,
mais même les rangs protocolaires
ont de l'importance.
Quand vous êtes ministre de plein
exercice, quand vous discutez
avec le ministre des Finances
de votre budget, c'est différent.
-Si ça va mal aujourd'hui,
c'est que ça allait mal avant.
-Bien sûr.
-Ce qui a été fait avant n'était
pas bien non plus ?
Parce que,
quand une catastrophe arrive,
c'est qu'il y a une continuité
dans l'échec.
-Il y a une continuité
depuis 2017, c'est clair.
-Et avant ?
C'était mieux ?
-Non,
en tout cas, quand je suis
partie de mon ministère,
la construction était pas en berne,
elle était en forte hausse,
on produisait 125 000 logements
sociaux par an et pas 80 000.
C'est des choix qui ont été faits.
On oublie ce qui s'est passé.
Evidemment que rien n'est parfait.
Il y a pas un côté blanc ou noir.
La difficulté à se loger,
elle est ancienne. Elle a amené
des politiques
comme l'encadrement des loyers,
comme la décote des fonciers.
Donc évidemment,
on a en France une difficulté
sur ce sujet-là
depuis longtemps. Ce qui change,
c'est qu'elle s'aggrave vite.
Je rappelle ce qui s'est passé
en 2017 dans les 1ers mois d'arrivée
d'Emmanuel Macron
au pouvoir
et notamment d'Edouard Philippe.
Dès juillet 2017, on décide quoi ?
De réduire le budget
des aides à la pierre
pour le logement social pour réduire
l'objectif de production
de logements sociaux pour les passer
de 125 000 à 110 000.
On enlève 5 euros d'APL,
de l'aide personnelle,
à chaque personne qui l'a
sur ce qu'elle recevait.
Donc y compris
des personnes qui vivaient
avec 600 euros,
on leur enlevait 5 euros
de prestations sociales.
Ca a commencé
comme ça et surtout,
depuis 2018, c'est la politique
du logement dans sa globalité,
et je ne remets pas en cause tout,
la politique du logement
dans sa totalité a contribué à faire
des économies budgétaires énormes.
-Oui, mais tout n'est pas
que la faute du pouvoir.
-Non.
-D'un point de vue
foncier...
-Laissez-moi terminer
sur les économies. En tant
que bailleur social depuis 2018,
les bailleurs sociaux contribuent
à hauteur de 1,3 milliard au budget
de l'Etat.
Nos loyers vont dans le budget
de l'Etat. Vous connaissez
un autre secteur qui le fait ?
On loge les gens les plus pauvres
et on nous demande de contribuer
au budget de l'Etat.
C'est un prélèvement à la source.
Aujourd'hui, on en paie le prix.
C'est-à-dire 6 ans plus tard,
la Caisse des Dépôts vient de dire
que nous n'avions plus la capacité
de produire suffisamment
de logements.
-Prenons le côté foncier.
M. Damon, les élus prennent prétexte
de la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation
concernant la résidence
principale pour limiter
les permis de construire.
Il y a aussi
le contexte environnemental
qui limite
l'artificialisation
nette des sols. N'y a-t-il pas
quelque chose à changer aussi
dans ce domaine foncier ?
-Ce qu'il faut, c'est limiter
la consommation de foncier.
Dans un français plus simple,
il faut limiter l'étalement urbain
et il faut
d'un point de vue écologique
contribuer
à une densification heureuse.
Ce sont des termes
que les urbanistes comprennent.
Ca signifie que plutôt
que de se concentrer,
comme on le fait beaucoup,
sur la construction neuve
qui reste nécessaire, la voie
d'avenir, à laquelle contribuent
les opérateurs du logement,
c'est la rénovation.
C'est pas prendre une grange
pour en faire une super résidence,
c'est pas prendre
un bâtiment haussmannien
pour le rendre plus joli, c'est
prendre une grande partie
de notre territoire déjà urbanisé
et en faire des villes
avec de l'habitat
de qualité pour tous.
Moins de consommation de foncier
et davantage d'utilisation
du foncier
qui est déjà artificialisé.
-Michel Cantal-Dupart, vous avez été
en contact avec le foncier...
-Je le suis toujours.
-Mais à l'époque,
quand vous aviez à gérer
le projet Banlieu 89, etc.
Ne pensez-vous pas que
les élus se défaussent quelquefois ?
-Je prends un exemple.
Les grands ensembles sont souvent
des quartiers sous-densifiés
dans les villes.
Sous-densifiés.
C'est des quartiers de mal vivre.
La seule façon de faire évoluer ça,
c'est de construire et d'amener
de la qualité là où il y en a pas.
Vous avez des espaces publics,
je sais pas comment...
Vous avez plus d'arbres
à La Courneuve
qu'il n'y en a
dans le parc Montsouris
à superficie égale.
Il faut savoir ça.
C'est inau... Enfin,
c'est invisible. Invisible. Donc
il y a vraiment repenser tout ça.
Ca devrait être
le rôle de l'ANRU...
-C'est quoi, l'ANRU ?
-L'Agence nationale
de Rénovation urbaine.
Ils s'occupent
des quartiers dits difficiles.
A laquelle vous participez
très activement.
Mais là-dessus, il y a une volonté
des élus de considérer ça
comme des territoires hors ville,
dans leurs têtes, hein,
on parle de greffe,
mais ils font pas grand-chose
pour ça. C'est hors ville
et c'est... ben, on va voir,
on démolit, on reconstruit,
mais il y a pas
d'intégration réelle, réelle,
de ces quartiers
qui sont des potentiels
formidables. Je vois...
Je prends un exemple,
c'est dans l'actualité, Pissevin.
Pissevin, moi, je l'ai connu...
-A Nîmes.
-A Nîmes, il y a 2 quartiers. Il y a
Pissevin et je sais plus comment...
-Le Mas de Mingue.
-Exactement.
Et c'était 2 quartiers, bon.
Moi, j'ai connu
M. Bousquet qui était maire,
je lui dis, c'est là le problème,
il faut unir ces quartiers,
au moment des ferias
de Nîmes, il faut
qu'il y ait de la tauromachie
là-dedans, que ça participe
de la feria. Autrement,
les gens viennent dans le centre.
Il faut qu'il se passe
quelque chose.
La DDE avait été active,
ils avaient
des terrains au centre
qu'ils avaient mis à disposition,
c'était formidable,
mais ça s'est arrêté là.
Rien n'a bougé ou pas beaucoup.
Donc on paie ça
très, très cher. Alors ça,
c'est une solution foncière.
Facile. Pour reprendre ce que
M. Damon disait. Il faut réinvestir
les villes et regarder où il y a
de la place. Et puis, et puis, ben,
vous avez ce que j'appelle
les phénomènes d'aubaine,
c'est-à-dire ces villes qui sont
plus dans la banlieue,
mais un peu dans la campagne,
qui sont dévalorisées,
où des tas de jeunes ménages,
autour de toutes
les villes, je connais bien
la région de Bordeaux pour ça,
les gens sont venus prendre
un habitat que j'appelle d'aubaine.
Alors, c'est
un jeune couple, des enfants,
si l'école est performante,
tout est très bien.
Ils ont 2 bagnoles.
Pour travailler dans la banlieue sud
de Bordeaux, par exemple.
Avec l'augmentation,
c'est catastrophique, de l'essence,
de l'énergie. Et là-dessus,
M. Macron, avant d'être président
de la République, avait eu une idée
formidable, qui lui avait été
soufflée par Transdev,
que j'avais moi-même
soufflée à cet organisme
de transport,
qui était les cars Macron.
Les cars Macron,
c'était pour justement faire
des circulations,
des transports en commun là où
ils n'existaient plus, au niveau
des départements.
Or qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait,
ils ont profité de l'aubaine
et ils ont doublé la SNCF.
C'est idiot. C'est idiot.
Il faut repenser un service
de cars, qui permette...
Parce qu'on est
sur un territoire en France,
foncier, vide, totalement vide.
Des tas de communes
sont vides.
-M. Lagrue, qu'est-ce que
vous préconisez sur ce foncier
à reverdir en quelque sorte ?
-Sur ce foncier,
je vais partager ce qui a été dit.
Une référence a été faite à l'ANRU.
L'ANRU, c'est important.
Evidemment, il y a
le logement et la production,
mais il faut aussi
tout le parc à rénover.
Et où je vais partager
le dernier propos qui a été tenu,
c'est le fait de dire
qu'à un moment donné,
si on a une forme
de désertification,
il y a une capacité d'accueil
qui est complètement abandonnée,
il faut peut-être se poser
la question à un instant,
c'est : et l'emploi dans tout ça ?
Répond-on à ce que le logement
aille vers l'emploi
et fait-on en sorte que de l'emploi
alimente aussi ce logement ?
Et ça, ça passe par quoi ?
Alors, moi, je vais le dire...
-Pardon, vous voulez dire
que le logement en France
n'est pas conçu
comme un élément
de la question sociale ?
-Absolument. Il devrait l'être
aussi, comme vous dites si bien,
de la question sociale
associée avec l'emploi. Pourquoi ?
Quand des salariés sur le plan privé
décident de devenir propriétaires
ou quand des salariés
louent un logement,
dans le logement social ou pas,
ils font quand même
aujourd'hui... leur problématique
d'être en proximité du logement,
de l'emploi pardon, emploi-logement,
il y a encore plus de sens.
Pour une raison aussi
qui est économique.
Je vous le fais très court.
Notre ADN,
il a toujours été
d'être dans le pouvoir d'achat
et aujourd'hui,
nous, on dit toujours,
régulièrement,
avoir un toit, c'est être bien
chez soi,
mais pour être bien chez soi,
on a un frigo à remplir,
et le frigo avec l'inflation
qu'il y a aujourd'hui,
vous le savez, et que les salaires
n'augmentent pas tout autant,
au plus on est
près de son logement,
au plus c'est un poste
sur lequel on peut
économiser, dépenser moins,
donc gagner du pouvoir d'achat.
-M. Damon, il y a une question
que je voudrais élucider avec vous.
On dit, depuis un certain temps,
que la hausse des taux d'intérêt
est invoquée
comme le facteur déclenchant
de la crise du logement.
C'est vrai ou c'est
simplement pour se défausser
sur... disons,
la déficience sociale ?
-La crise du logement, à mon avis,
elle est quasi éternelle.
Ceci dit,
celle dont on parle aujourd'hui,
elle ne date pas de l'augmentation
des taux d'intérêt,
elle est plus ancienne et elle tire
des racines
dans le phénomène d'inflation
qui pèse sur l'ensemble
des consommations.
-Elle se justifie économiquement
par les banques ?
Ou les banques en profitent ?
-Je ne saurais dire
si les banques en profitent.
Les taux directeurs
de la Banque centrale
font que les banques commerciales
qui font nos crédits sont obligées
d'augmenter les crédits.
-On peut pas encadrer la chose
pour permettre,
au moins pour les catégories
les plus défavorisées ?
-Peut-être faudrait-il regarder
dans le détail.
Pour les plus défavorisés, ça dépend
de quoi on parle exactement.
C'est considérer selon moi
que la crise du logement est d'abord
une crise qui affecte
les classes moyennes.
Les classes moyennes, on sait jamais
ce qu'elles sont exactement.
Admettons que ce soit
les travailleurs avec des revenus
modestes et là, je suis d'accord,
on a une déconnexion même
dans nos politiques publiques
entre le soutien à l'emploi
et l'accès au logement.
C'est préoccupant.
Il y a une des familles du logement
social dont c'est la fonction.
Il y a des financements
sur nos fiches de paie,
le 1 % logement,
c'est un tout petit peu
moins de 1 %,
ça devrait être dans une logique
de sécurité sociale devenir
une quasi-cotisation
ouvrant des droits. Alors, ça ouvre
des possibilités,
mais pas des droits.
Je voudrais résumer la situation
de la crise du logement
sur les taux d'intérêt,
si je la caricature,
elle est due à 2 phénomènes.
Elle est due à l'inflation
et à la lutte contre l'inflation.
A l'inflation,
car les coûts de la construction
augmentent, les gens ont
de moins en moins de sous
pour pouvoir payer
ce qui les fait bien vivre
dans leur logement.
Du côté de la lutte
contre l'inflation,
il y a la politique monétaire,
qui augmente les coûts du crédit.
C'est à la fois conséquence de
cette inflation dont nous pâtissons
et de cet outil important
de lutte contre l'inflation,
la politique monétaire.
-Je voudrais en venir avec vous,
Emmanuelle Cosse, sur la question
environnementale.
La rénovation environnementale
globale est insuffisante,
nous le constatons.
Et il y a trop de passoires
thermiques. Nous le constatons.
Des millions de résidences
principales sont
affectées par ça,
mais nos voisins ne font pas mieux.
Les Allemands ont cédé
sur cette question,
vous le savez bien,
il y a eu des problèmes
entre les écologistes et le SPD.
Ils ne sont pas arrivés
à résoudre la question.
Les Anglais,
avec le Premier ministre,
M. Sunak, a fait savoir
qu'on pouvait pas régler
simultanément les questions sociales
et environnementales.
Croyez-vous qu'on a les moyens,
les investissements,
pour permettre
ou supprimer
un maximum de passoires thermiques.
Est-ce qu'il y a les moyens
de le faire ? Ce que n'ont pas pu
faire pas plus les Anglais
que les Allemands.
-La 1re chose,
c'est un point de vue personnel,
mais je ne crois pas qu'on règle
les questions environnementales
si on règle pas la question sociale
et les 2 sont intimement liées
et en particulier autour du sujet
de la rénovation des logements.
Vous citez des pays qui ont renoncé
à une exigence très forte.
Vous auriez pu citer
les Pays-Bas qui ont eu une vision
très différente, y compris
qui ont un secteur bancaire dédié.
C'est un choix ancien.
Et c'est vrai qu'en France,
depuis les années 2010,
on tourne autour
de où mettre l'exigence,
le curseur et où mettre
les financements.
Il a été fait le choix
avec la loi climat et résilience
en 2021 de mettre
un curseur très dur
et notamment
avec une interdiction de location,
c'est un peu plus compliqué,
mais aussi avec un déploiement
d'argent, d'aides, de subventions
extrêmement élevé,
qui change un peu la donne
par rapport au passé.
Aujourd'hui, quand on est
propriétaire, y compris modeste,
on a beaucoup plus d'aides
pour faire les travaux
qu'il y a quelques années,
quand j'étais
ministre et je le reconnais.
Mais ça ne suffira pas.
Pour 2 raisons, d'une part,
se lancer dans des travaux,
que vous ne faites pas pour vous,
les travaux d'amélioration
de votre bâti, par exemple,
si vous avez plus de 70 ans,
vous avez du mal
à vous dire
que c'est pour vous-même.
-Oui, mais il faut débourser
au départ une somme d'argent
non négligeable.
Les Allemands n'ont pas pu
mettre des pompes à chaleur dans...
-Le système français d'aides
est quand même beaucoup plus poussé.
Vous avez compris cette alliance
entre les fonds de l'Etat,
des collectivités locales,
des subventions d'opérateurs,
une partie du secteur HLM, je rentre
dans le jargon, les Sacicap
qui amènent des fonds.
On peut payer presque
toute la dépense au départ.
Non, quand même, je tiens à le dire,
aujourd'hui, on a un soutien
financier qui n'a rien à voir.
Ca reste des travaux compliqués.
Et puis, c'est
la masse des travaux.
Il y a 2 choses, le fait
de le faire individuellement,
c'est compliqué, il faut trouver
le conseil, les artisans et aussi
le bon conseil pour le faire.
Et puis, en masse, je donne
juste un exemple, qui est pas
celui du financement.
Pour le logement social,
on a 5,6 millions de logements,
selon la loi,
nous allons devoir en réhabiliter
environ 1,2 million en 12 ans.
C'est un cinquième.
C'est une augmentation
du rythme très forte.
Ca veut dire une économie
qui se tourne vers la rénovation.
C'est une des difficultés.
Néanmoins, ça permet
de dire une chose,
aujourd'hui, il suffit pas
d'offrir un toit à un ménage
pour qu'il aille bien, encore
faut-il qu'il soit bien
dans son logement.
Ce dont souffrent
beaucoup de ménages,
et notamment avec le coût
de l'inflation et de l'énergie,
c'est d'avoir froid
dans leur logement. Il y a
un coût de santé. C'est renseigné.
Des personnes âgées
qui vont mal d'un point
de vue de la santé,
car elles n'ont pas d'eau chaude
et ne se chauffent pas.
Il y a une urgence sur ce sujet,
particulier par rapport
aux autres pays européens,
j'insiste, nous avons
beaucoup d'habitats
qui existent
d'avant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et la Première Guerre mondiale.
-Vous pointez la difficulté.
-Il y a une difficulté,
mais on peut la franchir.
Après, est-ce que le calendrier
imposé aujourd'hui est dur ?
Oui, il l'est. Est-ce qu'il va
y avoir des effets de seuil ?
Oui. Mais...
Je veux dire qu'on a quand même
des outils.
Les propriétaires sont acculés
entre faire les travaux, payer
leur crédit, payer la charge
d'énergie qui a augmenté
très fortement,
les taxes foncières. Vous voyez.
Beaucoup de ménages ont acheté
avec peu de revenus.
-M. Lagrue,
je vais pas vous chausser
de chaussures syndicalistes,
si je puis dire, mais vous êtes
à Force Ouvrière.
La question d'une concurrence
entre question sociale
et environnementale se pose.
Sur l'inflation, on considère
que ça pénalise pas
de la même manière
ceux qui n'ont pas
grand-chose dans leurs poches
et ceux
qui ont des hauts revenus.
Pour le logement, la question
n'est pas la même entre ceux
qui sont bien logés et ceux
qui sont mal logés.
Comment vous réglez, vous,
cette mixité
entre l'environnement et le social
dans un syndicat ?
C'est une question qui se pose.
Tout le monde n'est pas aussi...
comment dire, mal doté
sur les questions essentielles
comme le logement
et l'inflation ou d'autres sujets.
-On a toujours pensé
que beaucoup de choses doivent
se régler par la négociation.
C'est-à-dire que vouloir faire
de l'environnement
un ennemi de l'emploi
ou un ennemi du social,
c'est une erreur.
-C'est de l'idéologie.
On pense que de toute façon
on peut le régler par négociation.
Comment ?
Au travers des métiers justement
qui alimentent toutes les données
environnementales,
qu'elles soient dans l'industrie,
dans le logement, etc.
Il y a des secteurs
où on arrive à négocier. Prenez,
je vous donne un exemple concret,
on est en train de passer à la
voiture électrique, tout le monde
le sait,
quand on sait ce qu'il fallait
comme nombre de salariés
pour construire un moteur thermique
et aujourd'hui, il y a un écart,
donc un impact sur l'emploi.
Des négociations ont eu lieu,
des engagements ont été pris
vers une transformation.
Sur le logement,
c'est un peu la même chose.
Aujourd'hui, on a des outils
paritaires, on a des discussions
également qui doivent se faire
avec tous les acteurs sociaux sur
qu'est-ce qu'on met comme moyens,
comment on attribue les moyens.
Nous, ce qu'on veut dire par là,
si vous voulez, ce qui est
très dommageable aujourd'hui,
c'est que, si on laisse
la situation en l'état,
vous savez ce qu'il va se passer ?
Plein d'emplois ne sont pas pourvus
car les gens n'ont pas le logement.
Et il y a 150 000 emplois,
la donnée date de quelques jours,
150 000 emplois qui sont
menacés directement
par rapport à cette crise
du logement. Et je veux
terminer par une chose qui me tient
à coeur. Les anciennes
crises du logement qu'on avait,
et la dernière,
on a tous connu
la crise des subprimes,
c'était une crise financière,
mais c'était de la spéculation
sur les logements,
je sais pas si on se rappelle bien
tous les mécanismes. Aujourd'hui,
le problème, c'est
qu'il faut qu'on se dise autour
de la table quels moyens
on va donner au logement
pour que le logement puisse
au travers des mesures,
on parlait de l'ANRU, mais il y a
aussi les aides à la pierre...
-Mais cette ANRU
ne peut pas tout faire.
Cette Agence nationale
pour la Rénovation urbaine.
-Il est régulateur.
-Il régule quand même les fonds.
Vous savez,
la régulation va toujours
avec la négociation.
Quelqu'un qui veut se mettre
autour d'une table, on y arrive.
Ce que dit Emmanuelle Cosse,
j'en dis un tout petit mot,
c'est quand on pompe
l'argent ou les bonnes gestions
des acteurs sociaux que nous sommes,
des opérateurs,
Emmanuelle Cosse parlait
au niveau de l'USH,
au niveau d'Action Logement,
on est des partenaires sociaux
qui siégeons
dans Action Logement, on a
les 2 angles, la bonne
gestion de la structure
pour faire des logements sociaux
pour les salariés
et faire en sorte que les loyers
n'augmentent pas trop
et qu'en plus, on fait de la
rénovation pour que le logement
coûte moins en énergie.
Quand vous avez un Etat qui dit,
vous avez bien géré,
vous avez tellement bien géré
qu'on va vous faire
une ponction, ce qui s'est
passé il y a quelques années,
et j'étais déjà un engagé
comme je le suis encore.
J'avais très mal vécu,
c'était un autre gouvernement,
un autre président, la ponction
sur les fonds sociaux
de la formation professionnelle,
300 millions d'euros, parce que
ça avait été bien géré.
C'est insupportable.
-On le voit bien, la citation
que je vous ai soumise
de Jacques Ehrmann :
"Se loger fait partie
des besoins essentiels,
comme travailler et s'alimenter."
Alors, Michel Cantal-Dupart,
aujourd'hui, le cap social,
on le voit pas.
Les problèmes
s'accumulent,
l'inflation de 4 à 15 %...
Attendez, juste un mot.
Une baisse du pouvoir d'achat,
l'accroissement
des populations précarisées,
des modes de vie solitaires, etc.
Vous, en tant qu'architecte
et urbaniste,
vous pensez à ce cap social
ou vous pensez
au problème particulier
du logement ?
Si tout est dans tout,
comment voulez-vous
qu'on règle la question ?
-Je vais être très précis,
j'ai un âge canonique.
-20 ans !
-Oui, mais multiplié par 4.
Et donc, j'ai connu
la fin de la reconstruction.
J'ai commencé à travailler
chez un architecte,
c'était la fin de la reconstruction,
j'ai construit des grands ensembles
qui étaient l'espoir,
c'était vécu par tous
comme l'espoir, on va enfin
pouvoir loger les gens.
Je me rappelle très bien,
les gens allumaient et éteignaient
l'électricité en disant,
c'est formidable.
-Et l'eau.
-Oui, et les salles de bain.
On est d'accord.
Bon. Qu'est-ce qui a changé ?
Alors, d'abord,
la demande en logement.
A cette époque-là,
le logement, c'était
une famille. Aujourd'hui,
c'est une famille éclatée,
c'est souvent, trop souvent,
2 logements. En principe,
à proximité.
Vous avez commencé
en parlant de la demande
des logements étudiants. Vous avez
un truc qui s'appelle Parcours Sup
qui éclate aujourd'hui les étudiants
dans toute la France.
Je vois mes petits-enfants,
ils pourraient
faire des études et être logés
chez leurs parents, le temps
des études, comme ça a été mon cas
et notre cas peut-être.
Mais ils sont...
L'un est à Bayonne,
l'autre à Roubaix.
Ils sont éclatés en France.
Il faut trouver des logements.
-Il y a 50 ans, les étudiants
étaient dans des chambres de bonne,
ils avaient pas des studios.
-Oui, enfin, beaucoup habitaient,
dans ma génération,
c'était des gens aisés,
il y a la démocratisation,
mais c'était des gens aisés,
moi, je vois bien,
mes copains,
moi, j'habitais une piaule,
mais mes copains étaient
chez leurs parents,
tout était bien. Ca, ça a changé,
c'est une évolution,
une demande nouvelle.
Là-dessus, on a un gouvernement
qui ne sait pas répondre à ça.
Bien sûr qu'un ministre du Logement
est très important
et un ministre du Logement
qui prend ça en tant que tel.
Mais la réponse
à une politique du logement,
c'est interministériel. Je prends
un exemple, l'exemple de Pissevin.
Qui arrive là ? Le ministre
de l'Intérieur, en disant :
bougez pas, allez,
allez, 20 gendarmes,
Mais c'est pas une réponse !
La vraie réponse,
c'est globaliser autour
le ministre du Logement,
parce que ça concerne
le logement, le ministre
de l'Education nationale,
parce que ça le concerne,
etc.
C'est interministériel.
Il devait y aller avec 3, 4 gus.
Forcément la Première ministre.
On parle tout à l'heure
des collectivités territoriales,
les collectivités territoriales,
j'en connais plein,
elles veulent pas agrandir
leurs communes,
agrandir leurs communes,
ça veut dire agrandir l'école,
c'est pour eux, leurs financements.
L'école communale...
Ca va, un lotissement,
non, tant d'enfants, on peut plus.
Voilà. Et il y a un ralentissement.
Donc ça, c'est pris en compte
par qui ? Qui vient
aider à cela ? Je parle pas
des transports des gens qui vont
travailler. On vante le covoiturage,
c'est en train de marcher,
moi, j'y croyais pas.
Ca marche. Je le vois bien,
tous les matins,
près de mes échangeurs, les gens
arrivent, ils covoiturent,
il y a une certaine coordination
des choses.
Mais c'est quand même des pansements
sur des jambes de bois.
Il y a pas de pensée réelle
d'un développement
de ces quartiers très excentrés.
Et quand je parlais...
Tout le monde dit, mais le
télétravail, parce que c'est...
Mais le télétravail, les gens vont
dans des communes équipées.
C'est de l'emploi qui va
là où il y a
de l'emploi, du commerce,
on peut acheter ses cigarettes
et sa baguette de pain
à moins de 400 mètres. Aujourd'hui,
il y a des tas de villes vides
et que le télétravail ne touche pas,
parce que pour acheter
une baguette,
il faut faire 7, voire 14 km.
-Le pouvoir n'est pas responsable
de la gentrification des villes,
à savoir qu'il y a
des déplacements de population,
la sociologie urbaine ne dépend pas,
elle est mondialisée aussi, non ?
Qu'en pensez-vous,
M. Damon ?
-Nous, on est dans une république.
Chaque citoyen a
un pouvoir où qu'il soit.
Il y a pas de mec de la Creuse
qui est moins bien
que le mec qui habite
le Val-de-Marne. C'est pas vrai.
Et ça, on n'a pas encore
totalement compris ça.
-M. Damon,
sur une question précise,
puisqu'il faut quand même...
Les problèmes de location,
ces problèmes-là sont-ils liés
aux abus d'Airbnb, par exemple ?
-On peut répondre oui, comme ça,
je laisse du temps aux autres,
mais ce n'est pas la seule raison.
J'en vois une assez fondamentale
de spécificité française,
c'est que les investisseurs
institutionnels, du côté public
et du côté privé,
les assureurs, les banques,
se sont désengagés du marché
locatif. Les principaux
propriétaires,
je parle pas du logement social,
mais du locatif privé,
sont des individus.
Certains sont riches, méchants,
ils ont 10 logements,
d'autres ont 1 ou 2 studios,
ont du mal à mettre ça
sur le marché.
Un des sujets,
c'est comment faire
pour faire revenir
ces investisseurs institutionnels
pour plus de logement locatif.
3e élément, plus controversé,
je suis pas un inconditionnel
du contrôle des loyers.
Ca peut avoir ses vertus immédiates
et ses effets pervers qui poussent
une partie de ces investisseurs
à se retirer
du marché locatif.
Donc oui, Airbnb and Co,
ça a son impact.
Vraiment, mais vous le voyez,
c'est pas du tout le seul problème.
-Mme Cosse, est-ce que
vous pourriez nous dire,
nous donner
quelques chiffres ?
On entend dire qu'il manque
4 millions de logements,
il en manque 25 000 ou 250 000
pour les étudiants,
il n'y a pas assez de locations.
Si vous faisiez
un tableau clair,
il manque
combien de logements en France ?
Voilà, qu'on sache un petit peu,
parce que vous travaillez
dans cet organisme.
-Oui, vous touchez là des questions
que d'ailleurs
on va discuter au congrès HLM.
-Justement.
Combien manque-t-il...
-2 choses à distinguer.
Il y a le besoin en logements.
Vous l'avez très bien décrit
en introduction,
tout le monde ne souffre pas
d'une difficulté de logement.
Le besoin en logements,
on arrive à le dire.
On le voit avec les demandeurs HLM.
Il y a 1,7 million de ménages,
des ménages et pas des personnes,
1,7 million de ménages
qui attendent un logement social.
Elles ont du mal
à se loger ailleurs.
-En location ou en achat ?
-En location.
-Vous dites 1,7 million.
-1,7 million de ménages
qui attendent un logement à louer
dans le logement HLM
et, dans ces ménages-là,
plus de 60 % sont
sous les seuils de pauvreté.
Et la moitié est actif.
Très important de le redire :
qui a du mal aujourd'hui à se loger
par rapport au prix des marchés ?
C'est en fait un actif
qui gagne autour du SMIC,
à temps partiel
ou à temps plein et qui est
sous le seuil de pauvreté.
Vous voyez,
la grande différence
avec il y a 50 ou 60 ans,
où il y avait
des problèmes de mal-logement,
c'est qu'on n'a pas de réponse
à donner de manière massive
aux travailleurs à temps plein
gagnant le SMIC
pour se loger correctement.
-Pour la location.
-Même l'accession.
-Qu'est-ce
qui manque ?
-L'accession, c'est bien plus
compliqué. Je n'ai pas de chiffre.
On a parlé pendant très longtemps,
et c'est un chiffre qui revient
dans des études récentes,
d'un besoin en production,
ça veut pas dire du neuf,
mais d'arrivées
sur le marché globalement
de 500 000 logements, que ce soit
du locatif ou de l'accession.
A construire ou à...
-A quelle échelle de temps ?
-Par an.
-500 000 logements
à construire ?
-Je dirais
produire, c'est pas que du neuf.
-C'est du neuf
et de la rénovation urbaine ?
-Amélioration de logements
comme il y en a beaucoup
dans beaucoup de villes,
on en fait beaucoup.
Mais aussi pourquoi ?
Vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure.
On est dans un univers mondialisé.
Le besoin
en logements et le problème
de logements sont aussi liés
à la très forte attractivité
de la France
comme 1re destination touristique.
Globalement,
nous souffrons d'un manque
de lits et résidences hôtelières,
d'accueillir
ces millions de personnes.
Nous sommes
la 1re destination mondiale.
Toutes ces personnes
qui venaient beaucoup moins
il y a plusieurs décennies
se logent quelque part.
Donc il y a quand même
des études qui montrent
dans les fortes destinations
touristiques,
mais pas que les métropoles,
y compris des destinations
touristiques, La Rochelle,
Saint-Malo, évidemment Paris,
mais aussi Strasbourg, Lyon,
et aussi quelques joyaux
touristiques où il y a pas
un seul logement disponible,
pas un seul.
-Ni à la location
ni...
-Ni à l'accession,
parce que l'attractivité
et l'économie liée au tourisme,
cette année, c'est encore plus
important avec la Coupe du Monde
de Rugby et les Jeux olympiques.
Si vous êtes propriétaire,
vous vous consacrez
à l'accueil de ces populations
et ne gérez plus le tout-venant.
C'est des phénomènes
qui bougent très vite,
il y a 7 ou 8 ans,
c'était déjà un peu différent,
là, ça s'est accéléré.
Aujourd'hui, la fiscalité fait
que vous privilégiez
quelqu'un qui loue pour un touriste
qu'un propriétaire qui loue
à long terme
pour une famille.
Mais c'est des effets
de bord très importants, aussi liés
à la mondialisation, clairement.
De la même manière, les jeunes
sont éclatés plus qu'avant.
Il y a des phénomènes
de mobilité un peu folle.
Ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup
dans la période, c'est
qu'on gagne
des batailles intéressantes
socialement,
quand même celle du plein emploi.
Le sujet de la réindustrialisation
est très important,
fondamental,
y compris dans des territoires
où je me suis beaucoup engagée,
le bassin minier du Pas-de-Calais
et du Nord. On va amener
des milliers d'emplois
à Dunkerque, à Lens,
à Douai. Où est-ce que les gens
se logent en réalité ?
Il y a pas de logements vacants
dans ces territoires,
en particulier
dans le logement social réhabilité,
il y a pas de logements vacants.
Ce qui est très troublant,
c'est qu'on nous dit,
d'ici 1 an, d'ici 8 mois,
1000 personnes arrivent là,
2000 arrivent là,
et les collectivités demandent
aux bailleurs d'agir en urgence
car elles ne savent pas accueillir
cette population. Ni en locatif,
ni en terrain à bâtir,
ni en accession.
Et ce qui est étonnant
dans cette période, c'est que,
dans les années 50, 60,
Michel me contredira le cas échéant,
mais il y avait un accompagnement
du plein emploi avec quand même
un accompagnement par du plein
logement. Les grands ensembles,
l'accession sociale
à la propriété.
Aujourd'hui, on fait le plein
emploi, mais on dit aux gens,
le logement,
c'est un problème individuel.
J'y crois pas du tout.
C'est un problème éminemment
politique et régalien. Ca oblige
à ce que l'Etat intervienne.
-Michel Cantal-Dupart ?
-Il y a eu
un ministre qui s'appelait
M. Claudius-Petit, qui avait dit,
on faisait des grands ensembles,
et il a dit : attendez, attendez.
C'est lui qui a sorti le terme de
grands ensembles, parce qu'il a dit,
il faut introduire des commerces
au sein de cet habitat
et il faut introduire de l'emploi.
Ca a été les années 65.
Ca a été pensé comme ça,
mais maintenant...
Enfin, bon. Je vais
prendre un exemple qui va...
La ville, nos villes,
nos centres-villes
ont besoin
de 3 fonctions essentielles.
Des flics.
-La police.
-Les instits.
Et le personnel santé.
-Aucun n'est logé
dans nos villes.
-De ces trois-là,
qui peut habiter Paris ?
Qui peut habiter Paris ?
Qui peut habiter Bordeaux ?
Qui peut habiter Lyon ou Nantes ?
-Qui habitait Paris
il y a 30 ans ?
-Je m'en fiche des flics
qu'ils soient crevés,
des instits qui dorment
sur leurs bureaux, mais l'infirmière
qui me fait une prise de sang,
ça me plaît pas qu'elle tremble
parce qu'elle a mal dormi.
-Michel Cantal-Dupart,
permettez-moi de corriger
ce que vous dites.
-Tu peux corriger.
-Je vais vous dire.
Dans mon travail de journaliste,
j'ai interviewé il y a 30 ans
des grands universitaires,
y compris des prix Nobel.
Ils habitaient dans les banlieues,
pas à Paris.
-Bien sûr.
-Donc c'est pas nouveau.
-Mais la cherté...
-Non, non... On ira voir
la maison d'Aragon.
-La cherté du logement
à Paris est en effet
pas récente.
-Ils avaient des jardins.
-Et par ailleurs,
ce qui est intéressant,
c'est qu'il y a dans ces métropoles
un combat des collectivités,
pas que Paris,
pour faire revenir
ces fonctionnaires essentiels
au coeur de la ville,
y compris à quelques pas
de votre studio.
L'inauguration
de l'îlot Saint-Germain,
je me suis battue
pour le logement social,
où demain, ce sera ces fonctions.
Ce que dit Michel, c'est que,
pendant le Covid, on est tous
à saluer collectivement,
les travailleurs qui nous sauvent,
qui s'occupent de nous,
et pour nous quatre
qui connaissons bien la sociologie
des territoires, quand on gagne
moins de 2000 euros, on n'arrive pas
à se loger dans une métropole.
-M. Lagrue. Je vais vous donner
la parole après, M. Damon.
M. Lagrue, de ce qu'on entend dire,
c'est que le logement
est en situation
de pivot
de la paupérisation sociale.
Diriez-vous,
vous qui êtes un syndicaliste,
je vous réduis pas
à cela, mais
c'est un observatoire privilégié,
la réindustrialisation échouerait
si on ne résout pas
la question du logement ?
-Effectivement,
elles sont liées.
Elles sont extrêmement liées.
Cette réindustrialisation, tout
le monde le dit, est essentielle.
Quand je vous dis tout à l'heure
qu'il y a 150 000 emplois menacés,
pour le bâtiment,
c'est tous les segments du bâtiment
qui risquent d'être touchés.
Pour la réindustrialisation,
plus vous ferez
en sorte qu'on ait de l'emploi
qui revienne,
des métiers qui reviennent,
des savoir-faire qui reviennent,
vous allez
faire en sorte aussi que...
L'un va tirer l'autre vers le haut
en fin de compte.
Y compris même la partie privée.
Je vais vous faire
un tout petit commentaire sur...
Emmanuelle Cosse disait,
jusqu'à 2000 euros.
On se rend compte aujourd'hui,
un smicard, il a du mal, bien sûr,
mais celui qui a 1800 euros,
il a tout autant de mal
et celui qui en a 2000
parfois pour des histoires
d'effets de seuil et de plafonds,
il a pas d'aides. L'aide
à la personne, il en bénéficie pas.
Et son accès au logement,
c'est un vrai parcours
du combattant.
Et puis,
tout ça fait que le logement,
quand je vous disais
que la réindustrialisation est liée
donc avec le logement, la notion
qualitative, j'insiste là-dessus,
la notion qualitative fait
que si demain vous faites
en sorte
que le logement
n'alimente pas l'emploi,
quel est le risque ?
C'est qu'on paie moins les gens.
Si on paie moins les gens, on va
rajouter de l'inflation,
ils ne consommeront plus.
C'est pas un hasard,
vous parliez de chiffres
et je me suis permis de vérifier
une petite donnée.
La consommation en elle-même,
si on la met
en parallèle du logement,
la réindustrialisation, les emplois,
le logement et la consommation.
La consommation, en 3 mois,
elle a baissé de 11 %
sur les produits manufacturés.
L'alimentation en fait
partie. C'est absolument terrible.
A un moment donné,
tout va être relié.
Et moi, je pense, alors,
j'élargis
mon rôle de syndicaliste,
je me réduis pas à ce rôle,
sur la partie économique,
si un jour les banques centrales
décidaient
de dire,
sur les taux directeurs immobiliers,
on fait ce qu'on appelle
du financement
cantonné, on créerait un tuyau
spécifique pour le refinancement.
Les banques achètent l'argent.
En ce moment, que se passe-t-il ?
Quand il y avait pas d'inflation,
les banques empruntaient
sur les marchés financiers
à la BCE...
-La Banque centrale européenne.
-Banque centrale européenne, merci.
Ils empruntaient à taux négatif,
c'est-à-dire qu'en réalité
pour pouvoir lever des fonds,
on leur donnait un bonus.
Quand ils vendaient
le crédit à 1 %
avec un bonus supplémentaire,
ils gagnaient plus d'argent
en marge qu'aujourd'hui. Ca va pas.
-M. Damon.
-Je vais faire 3 commentaires.
-Il nous reste peu de temps.
-Ca sera très rapide.
Je voudrais résumer
le gros sujet
de ces métiers jugés essentiels
et qui ne peuvent
plus se payer la ville.
Il y a une très belle formule
dans les milieux de l'urbanisme,
ceux qui font vivre la ville
ne peuvent plus se payer la ville.
1er commentaire.
2e commentaire, sur les besoins.
Il y a des chiffres
un peu fétichisés,
le demi-million, les 500 000
logements nécessaires chaque année,
à construire ou à rénover,
c'est là qu'il faut
avoir une approche un rien
décentralisée.
Les besoins, certes on peut
les additionner pour avoir
une approche nationale,
mais ils sont
locaux.
Quand on parle d'immobilier,
il y a 3 dimensions fondamentales,
la localisation,
la localisation, la localisation.
La 3e chose, c'est mon dernier
commentaire,
on l'a beaucoup évoqué, c'est
le lien entre logement et emploi.
Nous fêtons les 70 ans
de la création du 1 % logement.
J'y pensais quand Mme Cosse évoquait
les années 50.
Ca a été une invention géniale.
C'est vrai que l'Etat a piqué
dans la caisse et continue
allègrement à le faire,
avec de plus ou moins
judicieux arguments,
et que les partenaires sociaux
localement peuvent
savoir ce qui est nécessaire
et pourraient, si ce 1 % logement,
ils en avaient davantage
la maîtrise, pourraient
mieux adapter
les politiques du logement.
-On arrive à la fin
de cette émission. Une conclusion
politique, Emmanuelle Cosse.
Jacques Chirac, quand il était
président de la République,
a proposé quelque chose
qu'il n'a pas réalisé,
à savoir
que les biens publics essentiels,
le logement,
l'éducation, la santé,
devraient sortir des normes
du marché. Vous y seriez favorable ?
Et sous quelle forme ?
-C'est une question...
-Notamment
pour les populations
les plus défavorisées.
-Je suis pas certaine qu'il faut
la sortie, plutôt une régulation.
En tout cas, c'est ma vision.
Et sur le marché du logement,
on régule une partie du secteur,
mais pas sa globalité.
Notamment on ne régule pas
ce qui est le plus spéculatif.
Voilà. Vous allez peut-être trouver
que je manque d'utopie,
mais je suis peut-être aussi
un peu trop
réaliste, je préférerais
quelque chose qui marche.
Déjà, si on régulait
le marché du foncier,
retourner à des régulations
très fortes
permettrait à mon avis
de répondre à cela.
Parce qu'on a
cette position française,
partagée
dans d'autres pays européens,
qui serait qu'en gros, le marché
du logement, il va se régler
tout seul. C'est pas vrai. Et c'est
pas vrai, parce que, d'une part,
notre marché est mondialisé
et qu'en plus,
la spéculation immobilière
n'a jamais été si forte. Donc voilà.
Je voudrais plutôt une régulation.
-M. Damon,
une précision par oui ou non
pour ponctuer...
-Oui.
-...cette émission.
Vous avez dit,
l'Etat pique dans la caisse.
D'après la Fondation Abbé Pierre
et d'autres,
on considère que l'Etat engrange
plus de recettes fiscales
liées au logement,
89 milliards, que d'aides directes
qui sont accordées, 40 milliards.
C'est vrai ou c'est faux ?
-C'est tout à fait
exact. Mme Cosse le répète souvent.
C'est pas 40 milliards, c'est 38.
Mais c'est une équation
qui me semble médiatique.
On peut la poser comme ça.
Ceci dit, les chiffres,
la réponse est oui,
c'est tout à fait ça.
-On va rester sur ce chiffre.
Je voudrais vous conseiller
une bibliographie.
Evidemment, dans ce domaine,
la Fondation Abbé Pierre
publie chaque année :
Son rapport annuel 2023.
Je voudrais signaler
les publications
du ministère de l'Environnement
et notamment de son laboratoire
environnemental, le PUCA.
Julien Damon, vous avez
publié un livre :
Aux PUF. Vous restez
sur la même vision ?
-Sur la question des SDF ?
-Oui.
-La question a formidablement
évolué dans le temps,
qui est aujourd'hui confrontée
entre autres choses à un sujet
très important, mais très sensible,
la question migratoire.
-Je voudrais
aussi signaler
les publications de l'Union sociale
pour l'Habitat que vous présidez,
Emmanuelle Cosse.
Nous arrivons
à la conclusion de cette émission.
Il me reste à vous remercier,
Madame Cosse, Messieurs.
Je remercie l'équipe
de LCP qui fait
un travail formidable
et, avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais vous laisser
avec cette citation :
"Chaque fois que l'on refuse
1 milliard pour le logement,
"c'est 10 milliards
que l'on prépare pour les tribunaux,
"les prisons, les asiles de fous."
C'est de qui,
ça ?
-Ca pourrait être Victor Hugo.
-L'abbé Pierre.
-L'abbé Pierre, voilà.
-C'était trop facile
pour que ce soit
l'abbé Pierre.
-Vous pensiez
aux "Misérables".
-Ouais.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA